the question of whether or not he'll be
the offensive rookie the year draftkings
has the odds out joe burrow is the
favorite at plus 215 which means if you
bet 100
you make 215 if joe burrow is the
offensive rookie of the year but chris
there are some intriguing names on here
and some intriguing numbers clyde
edwards hilaire the first round pick of
the kansas city chiefs at number 32 the
first running back off the board
plus 550. i like his odds better than
burrow because he's stepping onto an
established team he's stepping into a
position right he's going to have the
opportunity to touch the ball run it
catch it
gain yards score touchdowns be part of a
team that is high profile the media
members who vote on rookie of the year
are going to be well aware of clyde
edwards hilaire all year long joe burrow
may not have enough help around to make
kind of the impact necessary to win
rookie of the year i'd go with edward
solaire over borough at the plus 550
which means you win 550 dollars if you
bought 100.
yeah well i certainly think you know
burrow the bengals could be one of those
teams that exceed expectations as far as
next year is concerned definitely he is
going to have some talent around them
you know aj green should be back as we
know it right now and tyler boyd and joe
mixon and i thought one of the secret
great picks of
day two was the bengals taking t higgins
with the first draft pick of round two i
think he'll be a great compliment with
joe burrow but mike i'm with you
generally there you know it's about the
support system and what's there around
you to help you
to help accentuate your personal talents
clyde edward hilaire would certainly be
the first guy that jumps out to me the
game's just gonna be wide open for him
and he's probably the most dangerous
player him or cd lamb in wide open
spaces in the draft with the ball in
their hands so it really suits him that
way mike and i'll say i think after him
there's two more running backs that i
think i would throw right in the
conversation i mean jonathan taylor
behind the blue wall in indianapolis
watch out that'll be scary i mean his
power and speed he's a home run hitter
and then jk dobbins in baltimore i don't
know if he'll get enough carries but
again man lamar jackson around the edge
and then jk dobbins taking it 70 yards
up the middle he's another home run
hitter so the running backs i do think
are set up very well to make a run at
this thing
yeah i agree with you on that and
another one that stood out to me cd lamb
the cowboys receiver 17th overall pick
plus 1800 he's got the chance to have
and i don't want to say a randy moss
impact because there is no
uh a
real comparison to randy moss and that
disrespects the great year he had in
1998 but you got the quarterback the
offensive line the running back and you
got a starting receiver and amari cooper
who's going to be commanding double
teams there's an opportunity for lamb to
come in and explode with the cowboys and
i'm not saying he will but we shouldn't
be surprised if he does one other one
too chris and this isn't on the board uh
there are two steelers skill position
rookies chase claypool
and anthony mcfarland jr receiver and
running back respectively they are both
plus ten thousand plus ten thousand bet
a hundred they get it you get ten 000
for either guy i'm not sure which one i
like but the idea that you've got this
steelers team with ben roethlisberger
coming back would it shock someone if
one of these two guys just explodes as a
rookie with ben roethlisberger there
with juju smith schuster there it's not
going to surprise me at all
no it will not surprise me either you
know anybody that listens to my podcast
chris sims a button would know these are
two of my like hidden gems i love them i
call it robin hood right that's what i
call these type of guys where you know
we take it from the rich it or we take
it from the rich and giveth to the poor
i think those were two players that just
weren't talked about enough in the draft
process you know i saw chase claypool in
person a lot i've been around a lot of
high-end receivers in my life chase
claypool is brandon marshall vincent
jackson and i think he has a chance to
go in there and truly be like a number
one in pittsburgh he's got more physical
raw talent than juju smith schuster and
i do think he fits the way they want to
play in pittsburgh and with big ben
throwing you know his ability to throw a
great deep ball and back shoulders and
all like that it fits chase claypool so
i'm with you mike and anthony mcfarlane
you you open up the game from him he's
another guy he could take an 80 to the
house and we know they have running back
issues in in pittsburgh so i think those
are two really good calls for you uh by
by two guys flying under the radar here
put a hundred on it put your money where
your mouth is there bobby big chest
let's go
no i won't i won't
i should but i won't and it's always
good to have the robin hood approach
robbing from the rich and giving to the
poor and not the dennis moore approach
if you're familiar with dennis moore do
you know who dennis moore is chris
i don't no
tell me
dennis moore robbed from the poor and
gave to the rich stupid word that rhymes
with rich that's a monty python bit from
years ago which our friends in the uk
and ireland will immensely enjoy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports